sarah sarah lauren
[Laughter]
what's going through your mind girl i
think i know
what do you think is going through my
mind are you taking a cold shower
um i want to show you something
i keep my eyes wide
okay here's the thing okay it's best
grounded in reality grounded in the real
struggles of women
[Music]
sexy escapist my new addiction
is this the sexiest show you've ever
seen
why do i need to do any interviews after
you i mean you just hit everything i'm
happy
um is this the sexiest show i've ever
seen is that yes yes it is
and you know it's like i'm not just
saying this because i'm a part of it i'm
the first i'm the hardest critic on
myself
it is my favorite show i have ever seen
it really truly is it's so it it ticks
off all the boxes you know it's like not
only is it sexy
the story lines are incredible it is hot
it's shot really well but the stories
and the are just so relatable um
you know when the show has the courage
to really put issue issues and questions
about relationships and motherhood and
who we are it just has the balls i think
to put these
you know questions out there in a way
that no show
really has before being a mom yourself
is that part of what drew it to you why
did you want to sign on and how much did
you relate
oh yeah that was a big draw of why i did
this you know it's like i'm a mother of
three
incredible kids um but motherhood is
complex and it's super messy and you
don't have it figured out half the time
but i think you can be a great mom
and also wonder who you are i think you
know much like billy you can be a
great mom and still have this like
identity crisis of
you know where did that other girl go
what happened to those days where i used
to be
wild and free and unpredictable and fun
you know and so yeah that was a big big
draw for me
and also i just thought i just thought
it was so human it's like you know
i've been married and and in the past
and
it's just it's a it's a very human thing
it's just a very human thing
to acknowledge the fact that you know
the relationship
that we are in could not be one that
makes us happy
and i just i don't know i i just i had
to be billy come hell or high water i
just felt like i could relate and
and i had such a sense of responsibility
of putting her story out there you know
for people
i never had the wild experiences you did
i want to have them with you
because these are some of the sexiest
scenes i've ever seen in a tv show
as you're reading it on the page are you
thinking how am i going to do this and
as you headed into filming them
how did you kind of prep for it man
i have two answers so you know i have
quite a lot of emotional breakdowns in
this
and whether it was an emotional
breakdown scene or it was a new scene
it was prey now
you know it's like i have i have someone
that i work with to help prepare me for
things
and you know the sex scenes i would read
and
you know i would start i would get
turned on just reading it on the paper i
was like what is happening to me is this
normal
and um i was just hoping it would be as
good as i wanted it to be
and then the final product and how they
shot it and the music that they put
behind it i mean
we have such a pedigree of producers
from you know miles dale to stacey
rookhouser to everybody in toronto
that's producing the show i mean they
took it and surpassed anything that
i could have imagined i'm incredibly
proud and so grateful to be a part of
the show
i was just talking to mike and he said
the only thing is i'm doing the sexiest
show of my life
at 40 and the gyms weren't even open in
the pandemic for me to prep for these
scenes
yes yes that's so true it's so true so
what did you do because you look amazing
oh thank you you know i could sit there
and give you some
answer about how you know i worked out
and or whatever but no honestly i didn't
and i i i didn't work out i
um i was in every scene so it was
super hard to try to go running or
something beforehand
and also the amount of material i had uh
just really kept me busy
and you know i lived off of a steady
diet of coffee coffee
and coffee i appreciate the honesty
and i'll tell you when we first got shut
down i filmed for two weeks and then the
pandemic hit
and the first thing i did was pour a
whole bunch of m ms into a jar peanut
butter
and i think i i ate that for i don't
know like a week so it wasn't
it wasn't easy well you guys were able
to get it back going again
um i keep hearing about shows lately
this intimacy coordinator job
so when you're filming scenes again that
are on this
level how does that all work so the
world of the intimacy coordinator
you know we had a lot of sex scenes and
what we did we would rehearse on the
weekends
and we would discuss everything we would
discuss our comfort levels where you can
and can't put our hand
your hands so that way on the day
there's no real surprises and the other
important detail
which in my opinion is what really sets
the sex on this show apart from other
shows that i've seen
is we would pay attention to the most
minute things like for example the
breath
how are the characters breathing in the
sex scene is it
more intimate and is it quiet and is it
a lot of more just sort of like in each
other's eyes and that eye contact or is
it something that's more graphic and
more wild
because a lot of times these sex scenes
they're not just sex scenes they're
informing the emotional states of the
characters
you know with brad it was more sort of
intimate you know sometimes we use
examples from the animal world like you
know like okay this one is like
you know like two snakes bodies
intertwining and slow and sensual and
that whole thing and you know other
times it was more graphic and it was
hard and it was just it was a thing so
um it wasn't just you know sex for sex
we really choreographed things and paid
attention to again like
the most minute detail would help really
tell the stories of where these
characters were at by the way i'm also
obsessing over
how obsessed you and adam are with each
other on instagram
like this this is a sexy show and now we
got a sexy relationship
out of it what's it been like for you
two to be on the journey of the show
together to
be these two creatives together and to
have found love together
yeah well you know it it it um it was
great casting
i'll put it that way um you know without
sparing too many details because there
is a lot of uh
the part of my relationship that i
protect and it's for me and him only
you know it's um i'm very grateful that
i met him um
he's hands down one of the best humans
i've ever met and uh
i'm just you know i'm grateful to be on
this ride in general but then to be able
to
share it with him is um very special as
well okay i really i can't say i wish i
had more time with you and i rarely feel
this way
because the show's so freaking good
sarah it's so good
i have to wrap up with you but are you
ready for it to blow up
because i think this is the next netflix
addictive binge
are you ready for it to blow up this
summer i mean from your mouth
to someone's ears you know i just hope
they've got the same taste you do
we're left on this cliffhanger what do
you hope for a season two
and ultimately are you which team are
you on if we're gonna end up having to
pick between the two guys
well i'm on team billy that's the team
that i'm on you know and i feel like
the whole point about billy it wasn't
necessarily is that this guy or that guy
because i think we're better than that
and also as women we need to get out of
that
you know um the age will tell of you
know our lives are defined through a man
i want billy to find the version of
herself that she is the happiest and the
most free and i hope she can do that
without the help of any man no matter
who she's with
so that's the team i'm on and as far as
the second season goes man i hope you're
right
you know it's like we don't know and i
just hope that these stories continue to
spiral even more down the rabbit hole
that they already have and
you know billy's got to live in this
complex world of
sexuality like she's sexual and she's
unhappy and she's happy and you know
there's just a circus of things to
explore with her so i just
i hope we i hope we get another chance
to do it again because i sure do love
billy a lot